salvaging clothes washed away by floods
that hit various parts of Haiti after
torrential rains during Saturday and
Sunday
I lost a five-year-old child I risked
losing two children but God left the
other one hanging in a tree I saved one
but I lost one anyway my house was Swept
Away by the floods I lost everything
roads were turned into rivers of brown
Water many crops have also been damaged
in a country where many are starving
the world food program says tens of
thousands of people have been affected
most of the damage is reported in areas
around the capital port or France and in
the West
Haiti is already struggling with rampant
gang violence the head of the Civil
protection unit says that's impeded
rescue efforts
the rain coincides with the start of the
Atlantic hurricane season that will last
until November
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera